[Music]
let's go to cassandra in tacoma
washington hey cassandra what's
happening
hi thank you for having me on your show
i really love it yes that always makes
me happy
not not a lot of people love it hey so
what's going on how can i help
so i've had
multiple
failed romantic relationships resulting
in three wonderful kids they're nine
years apart 21 12 and three
dang gina 21-12 and three
yeah it's a big spread
so
there was a lot of trauma in my past and
so i know
that i was picking emotionally abusive
partners and
that i've done a lot of work to heal it
but like in the process just kept
repeating those kinds of relationships
yeah
i feel like i've done a lot of work put
in the work to heal
and that i was ready for a healthy
relationship
and so i started seeing someone a few
months ago but
i was struggling with
like not unloading on him about my past
but also like i knew i don't want to
hide my past i
i knew
before i met him that i wanted to meet
someone and i had to be brave and a
little vulnerable
and uh
just
i feel like uh
things came out slowly over
the last couple months in our
conversations and
you know he's been asking a lot of
questions and just um
feeling like he needs time to process
the information
and so i guess my question is i was just
feeling like meaning advice on how i
could have done it better and like what
i can do moving forward
sorry i can show them that i'm serious
oh so so how many times have you been
married
three three times okay so you have
you've been married three times and you
have three kids by three different
ex-husbands is that right correct yeah
and how old are you
42 42. okay so you've been married three
times
your first kid when you were 21
and then
okay very cool
and so here you find yourself
um
all three of these marriages dissolved
for
abuse reasons is that right primarily
there's definitely like
a theme of like
addiction and
manipulative behavior my dad was kind of
a mess that way so i picked similar
people sure
and you've heard me say on this show we
so often marry our unfinished business
and our bodies are always running
towards things that are familiar even if
it's not good for us right and so three
times you've looped back and been with
men who hurt you
and
or who weren't safe
and
then you decided to get serious about
healing when did you decide to do that
i'd say it's been like over a decade
even though i was still in one of those
relationships just kept like going back
but through that process kept learning
more and more about codependency again
it's like hoovering and love bombing and
all that yeah
so what do
what have you brought to these three
marriages that you want to be different
in marriage number four
i definitely can improve my
communication
i feel like
what does that mean
uh
i feel like i can write really well and
then when i try to talk it's all gambled
and like alphabet soup
okay
do you avoid confrontation
definitely i
would like
kind of freeze i guess
and then you take whatever crap
somebody's addition and then it builds
up and builds up and builds up
yeah and i felt like i definitely felt
like i've been a non-confrontational
person in the past but that i've learned
slowly like through work and things that
it's necessary cool so what happened in
this last one so you started working
about a decade ago
and you got a three-year-old now what
happened in this last relationship
um so i had left him and then shortly
after
became pregnant and just kind
sorry no it's okay
so you left an unsafe relationship
you all got back together
and then you found out you're pregnant
yeah so i i've always been a terrible
pregnant person like pre-term
labor and gestational diabetes i was
just really scared hold on hold on hold
on hold on
you're a terrible pregnant person or
yeah or you get sick
i get sick yeah those are two totally
different things you're not a terrible
pregnant person
you get sick
it's not like a
character or moral defect i'm a terrible
person when i have a lot of junk food i
act like an idiot
i get exhausted i get all bloaty and i
get grumpy that's terrible
just because your body gets sick you're
not terrible
so you get sick when you're pregnant and
so you've had a you had a hard row huh
yeah so i just knew
i i just
got scared and like
wanted some kind of stability and went
back yeah
are you safe now
okay
and so then one year two years later you
met who you think's gonna be husband
number four
the goal is i don't i i wouldn't say
that i've like
made a decision on that i need i i know
i need to go slowly okay
and get to know someone
and so in the process of getting to know
this person that you you kind of fancy
and you feel is the healthiest you've
ever been
you started on telling them about your
past and the struggles you've had and
the marriages you've had and the kids
you've had
and he said
whoa
is that right
yeah
tell me about that it's just been quiet
like
when i've had to say hard things it'll
be quiet and he just explains like he
needs to process he
like it feels very respectful and
um that he's
you know he's got a good head on his
shoulders and like i'm glad that he's
being thoughtful about this
what would you like him to do
um
it'd be cool if he gave me a chance
has he said i'm out but i know
no he hasn't it's just been pretty quiet
the last week so he's giving you a
chance i don't know
it sounds like he's giving you a chance
cassandra here's what it sounds like it
sounds like for the first time in 20
years
you've
you're talking to a guy that doesn't act
like an immature idiot
yeah it definitely doesn't seem like a
man baby
and
this is gonna sound nuts what i'm about
to say okay this is one of those cool
ways our bodies are designed but they
can get us trapped in a whole bunch of
mess
we can come to identify
the electricity and the chaos and the
um
impact if you will
of fights of anger of anxiety of
depression the chemical response as our
bodies dump into our system
to deal with those emergencies those
fights the running the freezing all that
we can get addicted to it it can become
the thing that we know
so you've been married three times
you've been in love three times you've
had kids you've had you've been through
childbirth with three different men
and your body remembers what that chaos
was like
and you know that that chaos hurt you
you know that chaos wasn't good for your
kid it wasn't good for the stability of
a relationship but it signaled love to
you signal connection however wacky that
sounds
and now you've met a guy who is
processing and before he pops off at the
mouth
he quietly says i just need some time to
process it this is a lot
and i need a few days
holy smokes did you know if every man on
earth responded like that
everything would be
better tomorrow right
um yeah feels like if he didn't want to
continue
pursuing me that i still feel really
grateful for having met someone like him
yes and hey i'll tell you there's a
bajillion of them out there
a whole bunch
a whole whole whole bunch
but here's what's happening in your
heart
because there's not an electric response
a loud response a volatile response a an
emotionally abusive response lots of
swear words and volume
there's a part of you however
dysfunctional this sounds
that is that is equating that to this
relationship isn't as good
this one doesn't mean as much this one's
not going to end up in marriage or into
a child or into whatever
and what i would want to encourage you
to do and since you're calling this your
first relationship where you are on a
healing path you're actually
saying what you actually need you're
being honest you're speaking up for
yourself you're not
um walking around in the shadows of your
own relationship and your own value you
are recognizing that your space
has worth
that
you're gonna have to learn how to be in
relationship with somebody who's
emotionally mature
yeah i knew like
from when i was
19
like dr drew used to say like
not to go for the person that gives you
that spark so i know like
that's something that's always been in
the back of my mind and that healthy's
gonna feel weird yeah it's gonna feel
different now there is tons of sparks
there are forest fires in
stability and safety you just have to be
intentional about them
they're control burdens right like
farmers control burn their fields and
then sometimes lightning strikes and
burns down the entire community
one of those is good one of those is not
they both involve fire
yeah okay so here's the next part of
risk and i want to applaud you cassandra
and for everybody listening who hasn't
been through three marriages and three
kids and three emotionally and possibly
physically and sexually abusive
relationships
and who didn't have a bunch of childhood
trauma the courage and bravery cassandra
you are showing by getting back up off
the mat after number three and saying i
still have value i still have worth and
i still want connection
is
it's strength that very few people on
earth will ever know
and thank you it comes with risk and you
know this intellectually
but your body hates risk all of our
bodies hate risk
you especially
because you've been through trauma so
here's the big risk
i want you to call him and say can we
have coffee
or can we go to dinner can we have lunch
whatever that looks like
and i want you to tell him
i put a lot on you and i know i've got a
pretty wild past
tell me where your heart is right now
do you still like me you still want to
be
my boyfriend he's still on a date
and when you ask that question
that will be as vulnerable as standing
naked in front of somebody
yeah because you'll be putting all of
the eggs in his basket he will be able
to say
i don't think this is gonna work for me
and that's gonna hurt like holy hell
and
you will have been honest for the first
time in a relationship he will you'll
have dated somebody who's honest for the
first time in a relationship and that
pain hurts and that grief will hurt
but that's going to be the first step
towards
this is what healthy feels like this is
what healthy looks like
if i helped you and it's scary scary and
here's what's here's what's almost more
scary
if he said yeah i'm still in
i'm still in
then you're gonna go oh gosh now you're
in uncharted water you've never been
with an emotionally mature person
and you're gonna be figuring this out as
you go here's the one thing i want you
to keep in mind cassandra two things
number one i've said it i'm gonna say it
again you have value and your needs are
important and you're gonna have to
practice being in a healthy relationship
that's number one
and you're gonna have to find a dance
partner who's gonna practice with you by
the way practicing can be tons and tons
and tons of fun
it's just different and scary
the second thing is this
i want you to keep
i wish when your body takes off on you
when it feels like ah this is all over i
want you just to try to back out of your
body for a second
and just look at your body feel it and
go oh man my heart's racing my head is
spinning out of control
my body's trying to take care of me
thank you body this one's safe
this guy's alright
remember all that work we did on how to
breathe and how to recognize when our
heart rate's taking off on us this was
just for that moment right now
right now
and thank you for taking care of me when
your back starts hurting when your neck
hurts you know you get that weird crick
in your neck
when you wake up 10 days in a row and
your knees hurt i want you to step up
and say
oh body you're trying to take care of me
again thank you thank you for that but i
like this guy
and he's safe
and i'm going in i'm going in it's going
i'm going to risk it i'm going to risk
it
and by the way just one more call out
for you cassandra you mentioned um
relational dumping
yes going slow is good
you've had a lot of heavy stuff in your
past
going slow is good not that your past
isn't worthy of being fully heard
but yeah there's a difference between
going slow and walking through people
and answering questions when they ask
them and then just backing a semi up to
their front yard and just
hitting the dump button and be like this
is me and it all just dumps in their
yard that can be overwhelming um you are
worthy of being loved and you are worthy
of being known
and yeah
you've had a wild ride
a lot of people hurt you you've been
through a lot of mess and
um slower is better that's wise good for
you cassandra let us know how that
conversation goes please write me back
let me know the conversation goes love
to have you back on the show and
i'd love to have him on the show love to
hear what he's working through and
thinking through
i could always use another emotionally
mature guy
for the world to hear that'd be great
especially on my show because
i'm not always emotionally mature thank
you so much for being brave cassandra
you're awesome awesome awesome